megan fox and machine gun kelly being  twin flames for a minute straight he was  like you're going to be naked tonight  and i was like whatever you say daddy  whatever daddy says he's not allowed to  have other hoes in his music video he's  the queen or no one goddamn i love looks  so good  these are my best friends that's how  they transport what do i do with this  this is a problem i don't know it's like  what should i do with this section  that's already done  hold on it's tracked you're you like  what  [Music]  he broke it  [Music]  you broke it so winded  oh yeah oh cause i ran i ran like one  quarter of a block  google any machine gun kelly photo and  then if you also google any meerkat  photo you cannot tell the difference do  that right now stop go away